if you've been using Skype zoom or any
other video conferencing app lately
you're pretty aware that not everywhere
can you use it the same and not every
video experience that you're on is
identical what's going on guys my name
is David homage welcome back to the
channel today we're looking at all the
different ways that you can host or be a
part of a video conference so we're
going to be looking at the video
capabilities of mobile phones laptops
and iPads and if it's worth going out
and getting a dedicated webcam and what
webcams you should be looking at so
let's start with mobile phones because
everybody has a mobile phone in their
pocket ready to go at any given minute
when a zoom or a Skype call comes up so
if the zoom call comes up and you pull
out your mobile phone there's some great
advantages to having your mobile on you
at all times one is the fact that you
always have it on you it is a great
advantage to be able to take these calls
anywhere in the world at any given
moment to is the incredible dynamic
range you're actually presented with
your mobile phones software features so
for example the s20 has a 14 megapixel
front-facing camera that can record 4k
the iPhone 11 pro max also it has a
front-facing camera that can record in
4k but is only 12 megapixels both of
them produce the phenomenal front-facing
video even the best selling smartphone
of 2019 the Samsung 810 has a 5
megapixel front facing camera with 1080p
quality so even at one of the most
budget-friendly
best selling phones of 2019 is able to
produce amazing quality content in 2020
but there are some limitations to using
your mobile phone for a zoom call for
example most people will hold it
handheld and it will be pretty shaky
you're going to be able to tell that
you're using a mobile phone for this
noon call people are also naturally in
tuned to hold it vertically instead of
horizontally from zoom call so if you're
sitting in
and everybody's on their laptop or using
their webcam you're going to be
orientated there absolute wrong way and
it's going to be very clear and very
evident that you're using a smartphone
another limitation is the audio quality
that you get from a smart phone smart
phones do have a pretty decent audio
quality but they aren't able to produce
the same audio quality output especially
if you're in a large environment or a
large room especially if you're outside
if you notice if you've ever been on a
loud speakerphone call you do struggle
to hear people sometimes in a loud
environment
so this is where headphones become a
very important feature there are a
number of ways you can combat the cons
of using a smart phone and my personal
suggestion would be to go out and get a
very cheap tripod that can just sit on
your desk when you're working and you
can quickly put your iPhone or your
smartphone onto this tripod and
eliminate the shakiness the verticality
and every other calm that comes with it
simply plug in your headphones or
connect your Bluetooth headphones as
well to get the best audio quality from
the device itself moving on to laptops
and laptops are actually a surprising
category here if we think about what
most people own most people own either a
MacBook Pro or a Microsoft Surface
laptop these two devices are some of the
best-selling in Australia and America
along with a couple of other HP products
and Dell products that isn't the
surprising part what is the surprising
part though is the fact that webcams on
laptops haven't really advanced in a
very very long time so as a standard
most webcams come in at 720p and most
brands don't even really tell you how
many megapixels are in the front facing
cameras because they're just a little
cheap add-on that nobody's really going
to use so as convenient and as I guess
good as you might think
a laptop's webcam is in reality the
quality of the webcam is significantly
worse than if you were using your
smartphone however there are some
additional
benefit to using a laptop over your
smartphone and that's a simple fact that
you have a much larger screen size the
screen size allows you to talk to
multiple people at once and have
multiple little icons of each individual
person on there without you having to
squint on the smartphone to actually see
who's who
laptops also have much bigger speakers
inside them which produce much better
sound quality so if you're in a larger
environment or a very eco environment
you are going to get much better quality
sound from a laptop
however because laptops aren't really
designed as photography utensils they
don't have the software smartphones do
so you're not going to get the great
dynamic range you know that tops camera
that you will in a smartphone if you
don't know what dynamic range is
basically dynamic range is the ability
to showcase shadows and highlights at
the same time so if you're standing
inside you're going to be able to see
inside and outside very clearly or not
at all and the outside would be
absolutely blown out or you will be very
dark so having a good dynamic range in
your webcam is very important especially
if you have a window directly in front
of you or directly behind you a good way
to combat this is by actually utilizing
it an iPad or any other tablet you might
have most tell us that are coming out in
2020 already having capabilities to
produce 4k video from their front-facing
webcams so for example the iPad pro 2020
Edition that's just come out a couple of
weeks ago features a 7 megapixel
front-facing camera that can showcase
unique glorious 4k so similar to what
this video has been produced in this is
the absolute maximum quality that you'll
be able to present to somebody else yes
you have to consider the limitations of
the program you're using for example
with zoom and Skype I only let you
stream in tiny P so there isn't a point
in having a 4k video camera it's just
down scaled but the software advantages
the audio quality the screen size and
everything
Twain makes it the perfect streaming
device okay so now let's say that you
don't have access to a laptop or a
desktop with a webcam and your
smartphone's camera is absolutely busted
you've dropped on the floor crack the
screen whatever you have to go out and
buy a webcam now I say it that way
because in my personal opinion I don't
believe you need to go out and buy a
webcam unless you absolutely need it
especially considering the ones that
will do even a half-decent job and give
you some decent quality images cost a
little bit of money so the first
recommendation I'm going to make up a
webcam I'm actually going to read
Because Logitech doesn't have fancy
names that have lots of numbers and
letters to make it different from their
last one so the Logitech c920 webcam at
a reasonable price on the market today
so for 140 Australian dollars you can
pick up this logitech webcam that
streams in 1080p not only does it have a
good image quality that's great in
daylight and in low-light it also
features two microphones on each side to
really capture the audio at the best
possible quality so a web camera like
this is one of the best investments you
can make if you do not have the
accessibility or options of any other
webcam available and any other device
my next webcam suggestion is for those
working in more low-light conditions and
again require some good audio at the
same time the razor Q I hope I
pronounced that correctly features its
own inbuilt ring light so the same
feature that's here in front of me now
lighting this whole background and scene
is actually in built into your webcam so
you're going to be able to present
yourself in an optimal light the
downside to this razor webcam is the
fact that it costs 220 Australian
dollars so it is definitely one of the
more premium webcams out there
especially for home use but it is it
targeted more at the gaming community
and the streaming community themselves
and last but not least is the Microsoft
LifeCam Hey
HD 3000 I don't know why we webcams have
terrible name but they just do so the
Microsoft webcam is one of the cheapest
webcams you can buy it's 48 Australian
dollars from most retailers and is
basically just the cheapest webcam you
can buy it streams in 720p which isn't
any better than any laptop out there on
the market at the moment and it doesn't
have any amazing audio quality or any
amazing video features it literally just
gets the job done so if you do need
something to just get the job done this
is the webcam I would recommend for you
now there is one other more techie
solution that you might not be aware of
if you already own a smart phone and
you're well aware of the fact that the
rear facing cameras are much higher
quality than any front-facing camera on
any smart phone well you can actually
use your smart phone and plug it into
your laptop and utilize it as the webcam
you can also do this with a DSLR so if
you have a big proper professional
camera you can again step up your video
quality to a whole new level this means
you do not have to go out and buy a
webcam to utilize something if you want
to use your laptop for example to stream
and have your calls and be accomplices
with other people there are a million
and one youtube tutorials out there of
how to connect your smartphone or your
DSLR to your laptop so just give that a
quick search or send me a DM and I'll
let you know how you can do it for your
device so what's the conclusion here
what should you be using to stream your
video calls and your video conferences
on well personally my suggestion would
be if you don't have anything accessible
to you use whatever you have because at
the end of the day it is really about
getting in front of these people and
being able to
connect when we're in a time that we
can't be connected if you do have a few
options though the best thing to use is
your smart phone your smart phone
produces the highest quality video that
you can get out of any of these devices
having a 4k video capabilities from the
front facing camera off a high-end
flagship will definitely produce some of
the best if not the best video that
anybody has on FaceTime zoom or Skype or
whatever happen using my only suggestion
with a phone is make sure you go out and
grab a small tripod place it
horizontally and make sure that you're
using it properly plug some headphones
in to get the best audio quality that
you can get and you're good to go if you
don't want to use a smart phone and you
do want to use a laptop or a webcam or
an iPad and all these three I would
definitely suggest going out and using
your iPad using your iPad will again get
you much higher quality video than any
laptop webcam or any built-in laptop
webcam I should say that's out there
right there so as a generic blanket
statement your iPad a new iPad at least
is going to be better than any old
laptop you have out with all these I
would always recommend headphones though
just for the best audio experience for
yourself and for the other people engage
in the vehicle and lastly on my list of
suggestions is a webcam I personally
don't believe you need to go out and
purchase a webcam
unless your computer doesn't have one
and you absolutely need one there is no
real benefit to a webcam versus a
smartphone or iPad or a laptop so use
whatever you have to your advantage and
only go out and buy a webcam if you need
that's all I have for you guys today
thank you so much for watching I hope
you enjoyed this video I hope you got
some great information
out of it if you did make sure you smash
that subscribe button
20:20 style and as always I'll see you
next Monday